please folks I only icon I can stay here
I can stand here all night and bask in
your love but there's too much important
information we have to get to starting
with it I must give you a public service
announcement have you heard about this
deadly new disease Mars okay it's not in
our part of the world yet but one of the
ways it spreads is by drinking camel
urine no I'm not joking about this so
the World Health Organization is issued
don't drink camel urine I know right
with the weekend coming up it wasn't at
that feeling you're pounding a couple of
rusty camel your engine you're like oh
I'm gonna pay for this tomorrow but
anyway and of course the other giant
threat that if you watch CNN it's 24/7
the escaped convicts from that prison in
upstate New York oh my gosh it's amazing
we're all still alive and now the
authorities up there fear that these two
could find their way into a large
population and blend in as Republican
candidates for president so many
well it is getting a little out of it
you know we have ten declared Republic
could get it by Tuesday or Wednesday of
next week we have three more we're going
to have Jeb Bush officially in Bobby
Jindal and Trump yes and then they're
still out there
Kasich Chris Christie Scott Walker is
going to declare they say by the time
the debates begin there could be over 20
an experts are projecting that sometime
in early 2016 is when the number of
Republican candidates will surpass the
number of women who have accused Bill
Cosby of it's a very but who cares about
that these convicts we got to get these
convict you know they're described I
love this as extremely cunning why
because they put lumps of rags under
their blankets in their cots to fool the
screws and just thinking they were in
the bunks when they were getting out of
it you know what if you fall for the old
dummy Mineta made out of rags routine
you cannot be a prison guard
but there is a place for you in airport
security
and I love this this is reported on the
legitimate news not CNN the legitimate
news said one of the missing convicts
yet this is handsome and very well
endowed with Sean it explains the error
of melancholy in the prison but look but
if you encounter this guy do not be
fooled that is a gun in his pocket and
he's not happy to see you now speaking
of the well-endowed how many saw LeBron
James penis last night on the guy yeah
that's right it what did you watch the
NBA Finals he was adjusting his junk
before the game and boo we got a glimpse
this is why we love sports in America
isn't it I mean the Super Bowl we saw
Janet Jackson's nipple now we've seen
the bran James is John so I better call
the police in McKinney Texas this
pool-party is getting outta hand oh you
saw that
you saw that I guess this week's viral
video police video a white cop in Texas
goes apeshit on a bunch of peaceable
black teenagers at a pool party it was
shocking
black people swimming oh right your
congressman I don't get but of course
now we're at the inevitable stage where
Rush Limbaugh and FoxNews try to figure
out how the victim was really a thug who
had it coming megyn kelly was talking
sensibly the other day about the
fifteen-year-old girl who had her face
pushed down into the lawn when suddenly
Megan was overtaken by clueless white
girl syndrome and she said the girl was
no saint either no sane yet cuz she
lingered and it reminded me is that we
know we think of megan kelly is the same
one over there at foxnews it's just
because she's surrounded by Hannity and
Bill O'Reilly she's like the blonde
dragon girl on Game of Thrones everyone
else is a zombie or a dwarf or [ __ ]
their sister so she looks normal
now hate to tell you this but Obama I
think had a very bad week first of all
we looks like we're going back into Iraq
which I don't like and he lost his big
Asian trade deal today it's too boring
to get into but just put it this way the
Democrats stood with the unions they're
people Obama was so with the Republicans
on this that he went into Congress to
lobby for it and House Republicans stood
up and cheered for Obama now they
thought he was dr. ben Carson but still
they that says a lot dr. ben is one of
the Ted is tickly yo you know who else
has declared and made news yesterday
Lindsey Graham you know Lindsey Graham
the senator from South Carolina this but
he's been dogged by rumors for a long
time that he was gay he actually came
out did not come out he he said
yesterday he actually gave an interview
and said quote I am gay sorry
many said but that was before I saw
LeBron James no no I
I take Lindsay at his word if he says
he's not gay he's not gay good enough
for me although today they asked him
about what to do about the violence in
the Middle East and he said lotions can
no longer protect us so I not oceans
lotions can I I just seemed a little
gate never me anyway so he another
declared candidate Mike Huckabee had a
rough week he Mack Huckabee last week
was defending his friendship with the
child molester Josh Duggar Mike's now
being asked about the fact that the guy
who co-wrote his book you know they all
have a campaign book his his called
character makes a difference the guy who
co-wrote it with them he's facing two
lawsuits about being a child molester
doesn't anyone in that party just want
to have sex with an adult woman and
Rick Santorum is not this affiliated
with child molesters and he's Catholic
but but it does explain Mike Mike
Huckabee's getting campaign slogan which
is Huckabee get in my car and help me
look for the dog
you